das ist ein wirklicher wissenschafts
skandal an deutschen universitäten
werden viele klinische studien
durchgeführt die medikamente auf ihre
wirkungen und nebenwirkungen untersuchen
und eine aktuelle untersuchung zeigt
jetzt dass viele studien ergebnisse
einfach nicht veröffentlicht werden was
für patientinnen eine absolute
katastrophe ist weil sie nicht nach den
neuesten erkenntnissen behandelt werden
können doch jetzt drohen strafen klicks
und science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's aktive
kommen klinische studien sind
medikamentenstudien die an menschen
durchgeführt werden für mediziner innen
sind die ergebnisse aus solchen studien
extrem wichtig um die bestmögliche
therapie für ihre patientinnen zu finden
dazu müssen ärztinnen weltweit zugang zu
den neuesten studien resultaten haben
und das geht nur mit einer umfassenden
datenbank in europa gibt es dafür dass
at t das european junior aggregation
autorität klinikbetreibers in diesem
eu-weiten register werden seit 2004
klinische studien erfasst seit 2014
müssen darin außerdem alle ergebnisse
solcher klinischer studien
veröffentlicht werden verpflichtend das
muss spätestens ein jahr nach abschluss
einer studie passieren egal ob sie von
einem fachjournal publiziert werden soll
oder nicht eigentlich eine richtig gute
und vor allem klare sache aber nur
eigentlich denn einige deutsche
universitätskliniken kommen dieser
verpflichtung einfach nicht nach einer
analyse der britischen kampagne
transparent und der deutschen buko
pharma kampagne brachte jetzt
schockierende tatsache nicht sie deckte
auf dass es für zahlreiche deutsche
universitäten sogar nur die ausnahme
darstellt ihre studienergebnisse
überhaupt im zentralen register zu
erfassen die zahlen sind erschreckend
die 35 deutschen unikliniken haben
insgesamt 1312 studien im register
angemeldet 477 davon sind seit über
einem jahr abgeschlossen es müssten also
auch 477 studienergebnisse abrufbar sein
in der realität sind es aber gerade mal
32 das sind nicht mal sieben prozent zum
großteil haben mediziner innen oder
andere forscher innen also gar keine
möglichkeit auf diese ergebnisse
zurückzugreifen für kranke menschen kann
das schwerwiegende folgen haben da ohne
das nötige wissen
entscheidende therapie fehler gemacht
werden können das traurige daran ist
dass dieses wissen ja eigentlich da wäre
aber es bleibt unter verschluss und das
in ganz deutschland 17 universitäten
teilen überhaupt keine ergebnisse im
europäischen register schlecht sieht es
in regensburg würzburg leipzig und
düsseldorf aus hier werden lediglich
zwischen 20 und 29 prozent der
studienergebnisse veröffentlicht
schlecht sieht es auch an der berliner
charité aus hier fehlen die daten von 68
prozent der studien vom klinikum der
universität münchen fehlen resultate von
29 studien von der technischen
universität münchen 27 studien die
medizinische hochschule hannover
schuldet dem register noch ergebnisse zu
26 abgeschlossenen studien viele davon
sind bereits seit jahren beendet die
einzige positive ausnahme ist das
universitätsklinikum münster von dem
immerhin 61 prozent der
studienergebnisse registriert sind dabei
geht es in vielen fällen um schwere
krankheiten wie parkinson oder krebs
wenn sie im register nicht abrufbar sind
bleiben die studienergebnisse erstmal
nutzlos weil sie nicht in therapien
einfließen können eine katastrophe für
schwerkranke patientinnen die täglich
auf neue ergebnisse aus der wissenschaft
hoffen und auch für die probanden dieser
studien dürfte das ein harter schlag
sein der ihr vertrauen in die
wissenschaft zumindest stört wie kann es
sein dass so viel geforscht aber nur so
wenig davon sauber dokumentiert wird die
süddeutsche zeitung der wdr und ndr
haben nachgehakt und die universitäten
mit dem problem konfrontiert viele von
ihnen reden sich einfach damit heraus
dass die veröffentlichung im euter c
noch nicht verbindlich sei und sie ihre
ergebnisse im deutschsprachigen register
farmen nett und ein gegeben hätte das
wird aber weltweit kaum zur kenntnis
genommen und hat damit keinen großen
wert für die internationale medizin die
uni freiburg von der die ergebnisse aus
14 studien fehlen erklärte dass die
veröffentlichung in der eu datenbank
sehr aufwendig sei und es keine
gesetzliche verpflichtung dazu gebe das
zuständige bundesinstitut für
arzneimittel und medizinprodukte sieht
das auf anfrage aber ganz anders und
betont das zitat alle relevanten
ergebnis bezogenen informationen in der
eu datenbank öffentlich zugänglich sein
müssen
eine klare ansage neben dem
bundesinstitut ist auch das
paul-ehrlich-institut das deutsche
bundesinstitut für impfstoffe und
biomedizinische arzneimittel für die
überprüfung des registers
ständig anscheinend hatte die es den
universitäten mitgeteilt dass keine
maßnahme erforderlich ist das sind zwei
widersprüchliche aussagen der
zuständigen aufsichtsbehörden die
offensichtlich für desinformation an den
unis sorgen beiden aufsichtsstellen ist
das problem mittlerweile bewusst und
dennoch sind die verantwortlichen bisher
nicht aktiv geworden
das bundesinstitut für arzneimittel
hatte lediglich im letzten sommer die
leiter von klinischen studien darauf
hingewiesen dass die veröffentlichung
nötig sei vom wirklichen maßnahmen fehlt
aber jegliche spur und damit auch der
anreiz für die universitäten etwas zu
ändern kritiker in fordern deshalb
konsequenzen bei nicht veröffentlichung
von studien solle den universitäten
künftig der geldhahn abgedreht werden
und studien erst dann wieder gefördert
werden wenn die ergebnisse im register
erfasst worden sind alles andere sei
eine verschwendung von öffentlichen
geldern einen blick über deutschland
hinaus zeigt dass es auch anders geht
werden in deutschland nur sieben prozent
der ergebnisse im eu register
veröffentlicht wurden liegt der
durchschnitt in europa bei 63 prozent
aus den vereinigten staaten wurden sogar
69 prozent eingegeben klinische studien
sind notwendig für den medizinischen
fortschritt sie haben eine unmittelbare
relevanz für die fachwelt und die
betroffenen patientinnen vor diesem
hintergrund sollte doch der mehraufwand
die einzelne ergebnisse der studien eu
register zu erfassen machbar sein
schließlich geht es um medikamente nach
nierentransplantation gegen diabetes
multiple sklerose und andere schwere
krankheiten wie funktioniert eine
spritze ohne nadel medizin der zukunft
bei doktor watson anklicken anschauen
und doktor watson unbedingt abonnieren
sehr sehr cooler kanal bleibt dran
neben bis dann bleib dran